[Music]
it's been many years since i first
started watching anime
many years that have molded me into the
depressed addicted and
frankly pretty degenerate weeb that i am
now
but before this journey of mine one that
we've all ventured on whether it was
many eons ago like me
or only a couple days ago we were all
fresh-faced youths with lives ahead of
us
and there's certainly many things i wish
i could have told myself before i began
this
adventure into the world of anime this
world that has brought me so much
joy wonder and excitement but one that
has also
torn my heartstrings enough to the point
of no return
from the first excitement i felt from
kirito dual wielding and sword art
online
to the recent sob story of to your
eternity
there are and always will be endless
things that i can talk about in anime as
more come out
but alas today i will break down the
five things i wish i knew before
all that even began the things i wish i
could have told to that fresh-faced
youth
good or bad
i have a bad feeling about this and the
first thing i would tell myself off the
bat of course is that
i would soon develop a crippling
addiction to 2d girls
yes with all the senjaharas maisons
mizuharas kurisus
wait a second well let me check this out
real quick
oh and no no take that back take that
back rewind it
this should really come as no surprise
if you're sitting there behind your
screen thinking
what they're just animated characters i
would never fall in love with one
just you wait buddy you will it's really
only a matter of time
i mean there's an entire market for body
pillows of anime girls and
let's be honest with the presence of
anime like high school of the dead and
high school dxd
anime studios are on a very purposeful
agenda to make sure that every single
anime watcher becomes obsessed
with not just the charismatic lead
character but the beautiful women
accompanying him in his harem too
of course this isn't always developed in
such a
straightforward way i guess as it is in
the shows that i just mentioned
many of the best waifus and anime are
found through completely great romance
stories which are not completely
perverted
they're very wholesome actually though
there's always fan service type moments
girls like kurisu or mai-san
are praised for just how great of
characters they are
they fill the hole that us lonely anime
watchers have
so lonely they're the kinds of women who
would actually approach the lame weirdo
in the series
giving all of us watchers hope we can
only help but cling to that hope
the bait that anime studios and manga
writers are hanging in front of our
innocent faces
as we continue through life being
rejected left and right
finding nothing but anime as our solace
we must keep that flame lit
as we search for our irl waifus keep
your head up king
and this actually segues quite well into
the second thing i would have wished to
tell my past
self which is how anime would end up
breaking my heart in ways that no woman
ever will oh touch grass bro go outside
okay well tell me do they have dry
outside
do they do they have nina tucker out
there
no relationships are temporary they can
be found again
but they they will never come back
see sword art online and death note my
first anime aside from childhood shows
like naruto and dragon ball z
were too misleading i thought it would
be these fun and games where i'm
actually rooting for characters to die
more often than not
that it would all just be cool fights
and rivalries but this
could not have been further from the
truth i will never
forget the first time i watched your lie
in april and proceeded to cry tears
comparable to the flooding of the hoover
dam
afterwards anime over the years has
broken me in parts of my mind
i never even knew existed and so
honestly
even though i wish i knew this
beforehand nothing truly could have
prepared me for the
innumerable beautiful sad and touching
moments in all of anime
wow i i really am just living
vicariously through anime aren't i
number three that i would someday end up
watching a show with over 970 episodes
yes we all know it one piece
the timeless monolith that continues to
reign over anime as if it isn't like
10 times older than any other airing
anime that still exists
swear to god it's like you go to a party
with your friends and then your dad
shows up to the party and then
out drinks everyone that's one piece
and the best part is it's so god
good no matter how impatient you are how
little time you have on your hands
just about every possible experience you
can find
within all of anime one piece has done
at some point from tear-jerkers you'd
want from a good slice of life
to epic wins and battles from a shonen
to team moments you'd expect from a
sports anime
to storytelling akin to the best of the
best slow burning anime
it should come as no surprise that in
the 970 plus episode journey one piece
has done
it's done all of these or will do it at
least by the time it's over
which let's be honest it's probably in
like another decade
being real with myself i'm probably
gonna be a father by the time this anime
finishes which
actually that'll be perfect because that
means i can go straight into a re-watch
with my kids
stop it get some help i don't think
anyone as kids
ever knew that a show this long existed
being exposed to you know seasonal
western shows like the office or
sitcom crap like that let alone that
they would end up watching and binging
all of it in my prime one piece watching
days like
four years ago maybe i watched 46
episodes of marine ford in a single day
like doing the math that's like i don't
know that's a lot of time
i ate crapped and watched one piece
that's all i did in a single 24-hour
period
and honestly still one of my proudest
moments
they need to make another one piece man
i want that experience again
the fourth thing that i really really
wish i told myself about was the uh
the crowd i'd end up being associated
with
i love anime fans don't get me wrong i
love all 3924 of you that are subscribed
to me
and many of my actual irl friends watch
anime too but
man some people just ruin it i said i
was living vicariously through anime
earlier
but my many treks on tiktok have taught
me that this is an
understatement for some people oh my god
sugoi
baka you're my sassy baca
the comment section on these posts is
bewildering to say the least
and i mean a lot of this stems from the
waifu and stan culture that i mentioned
before in my first point
but you know just be like me buy a
secret body pillow and
move along with your day
and alas my last point
the paramount and biggest thing i wish i
knew or was at least prepared for when i
first started watching anime
is just how incredible and life-changing
it is
yes we are pulling a complete 180 now
because i do feel morally obligated to
mention the
impact that anime can have and that it's
had on myself
never could i have foreseen making
videos every week on anime let alone
dedicating my time to anything that much
but
the worlds that have been built the
characters i've witnessed rise and fall
the stories that have immersed me and
left me in sheer awe
or fear or tears it's all something that
extends far beyond the cartoons i
initially thought they were you know at
the end of the day
in spite of my attraction to females of
the 2d realm
the days days i've dedicated solely to
watching a stretchy pirate punch people
the countless tissues i've had to spend
money on to mop up my tears and
other fluids after my favorite character
dies and my hatred
for anime tick tocks that push it too
far i love anime
i still do and i wish that my younger
self knew just how much of an impact
it would have on me in the years to
follow and the years to come
make sure to leave a like and comment
down below if you enjoyed the video i
had tons of fun making it
[Music]
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga
and character analyses
you